hi
i'm lucas morel the john k boardman
junior professor of politics and head of
the politics department at washington
and lee university in lexington virginia
i'm also a visiting teaching fellow at
the kirby center
the school of government in washington
dc for hillsdale college welcome to this
symposium on
race in america i'll be speaking today
on a colorblind constitution
abraham lincoln once said that the
central idea of american public opinion
from the beginning was the equality of
men
the problems of course arose when the
idea was undermined by the continued
practice
of racial slavery as it was defended
no longer as a necessary evil but as a
positive good if you can believe it
good for the master and the slave
even though the defenders of slavery
were defeated in the civil war
white supremacy still reigned throughout
the south
well into the 20th century and so a
nation that began
as the first in human history devoted to
the self-evident truth that all men are
created equal
still wrestles with the role that race
should or should not play
in government policy put simply should
americans govern themselves
in a color-blind fashion when it comes
to the rule of law
or should we use race to try to
eliminate
the lingering effects of racial slavery
and segregation
put simply should americans govern
themselves
in a colorblind fashion when it comes to
the rule of law
or should we use race to try to
eliminate the lingering effects
the legacy as they say of racial slavery
and segregation
one of the greatest american orators of
the 19th century
this gentleman an escaped slave and
abolitionist orator
frederick douglass began his public
career
criticizing the united states
constitution as a pro-slavery document
douglas asked what country have i the
institutions of this country do not know
me
they do not recognize me as a man
and so he concluded i have no love for
america
to his credit and this countries he did
not hold that position for long
he eventually claimed america as his
country
calling the principles of the
declaration of independence
saving principles and the constitution
no longer as pro-slavery
but a glorious liberty document
he found that reading the constitution
the way his former mentor
william lloyd garrison read it as a
pro-slavery document
contradicted its preamble and gave short
shrift to the many levers of freedom
found therein he also noticed that the
constitution
actually never mentioned the word slave
or
slavery or race and it permitted the
congress to actually ban the importation
of slaves
as early as 1808 which they actually did
he said therefore that it leans to
freedom not
slavery and look to the abolition of
slavery
rather than its perpetuity planting his
political identity
firmly in his citizenship it led this
former slave
who had every reason to hate america to
become one
of her greatest defenders on the
question of race in the constitution
frederick douglass was clear
quote color should not be the criterion
of rights
end quote he also said i know of no
rights of race
superior to the rights of humanity
when asked what he would do if he were
president of the united states
after he stopped laughing because that
was absurd at that time he knew it would
never happen
he replied i would secure to every
citizen of the united states
without regard to color or sex or
religion or
race equal protection of the laws
if all men are created equal then their
government should protect them
equally secure what each member
of the political community possesses
equally namely
their natural rights douglas's plain
reading of the constitution
and the declaration of independence led
him to conclude that
blacks should not be made an exception
in the law this would reinforce the
stereotype of racial inferiority
and undermine the central idea that all
men are created equal
douglas always considered the impact
that public policy would have
on how whites treated and viewed black
americans
and therefore he didn't favor any
government practice
that would relieve black americans of
any duty or responsibility
that was expected of all other americans
we do not solicit unusual favor he said
but will be content with rough-handed
fair play
he went on to add we are neither lame or
blind
that we should seek to throw off the
responsibility
of our own existence or to cast
ourselves
upon public charity for support
but as much as douglas did to promote
the elevation of blacks in america
he actually was not a fan of what we
would today call
race pride he called it a false
foundation and a positive evil
he proclaimed it the very thing we're
fighting against
for most of american history black
americans wanted nothing to do with a
color line
that separated them from the rest of the
american population
he wrote that it was our enemies who
sought to quote deepen
and widen the line of separation between
the white
and colored people of this country
given that blacks were a numerical
minority in the united states
racial solidarity was never the key
to gaining greater security and
protection
of their civil and political rights
his argument against race pride led him
to criticize what he called
complexional institutions over a decade
before lincoln was elected president
douglas argued quote that all
distinctions founded
on complexion ought to be repealed
repudiated and forever abolished
every right privilege and immunity now
enjoyed by the white man
ought to be as freely granted to the man
of color he thought that
for example colored conventions as they
called it then colored exhibitions
colored associations and institutions he
said these are hindrances rather than
helps
in achieving a higher and better
estimation for the black man
in the public mind his concern for the
impact
of public policy on public opinion
led him to argue against any recognition
of
race or color when it came to government
policy
it's safe to say that douglas was not a
practitioner
of identity politics so
have the american people ever adopted
douglas's
clear belief in a colorblind
constitution
after the 14th amendment was ratified
just a few years after the end of the
civil war
the supreme court began to decide cases
involving
equal treatment under the law one of the
key clauses of the 14th amendment
requires that no state shall quote
deny to any person within its
jurisdiction
the equal protection of the laws end
quote
this would seem to ban any government
use of racial classifications
but unlike douglas who did not believe
race should be the measure of anyone's
constitutional rights
to this day the supreme court has never
adopted or interpreted
the constitution to be a colorblind
constitution
instead it has reserved to itself the
authority
to decide when government use of race
is constitutional and when it is not
ironically it was a lone dissenting
opinion
that introduced the concept of a
colorblind constitution
however that dissenting justice was
outnumbered by seven justices who
interpreted the constitution to permit
government use of race as long as it was
done in
as they call it a reasonable fashion
what was later known as the rational
basis test
permitted large discretion on the part
of state governments
to employ racial classifications to
promote the peace safety
and comfort of the community
that case was plessy v ferguson an 1896
ruling that gave us that
the notion that separate but equal was
all right
it was an acceptable measure of whether
one's race was being used in a
constitutional way
by state government this pernicious
standard
was precedent for subsequent cases until
the landmark decision
in brown v board of education of topeka
kansas in 1954
it ruled unanimously that racial
segregation of public schools
deprives students of quote the equal
protection
of the laws guaranteed by the 14th
amendment
end quote the naacp
the national association for the
advancement of colored people they
provided the lead
group of attorneys in these cases
their in-house legal defense fund known
as known as the fund
had for decades not attacked
segregation laws directly but had argued
and argued successfully
that segregation was unconstitutional
because it did not apply
equally to citizens of all races
they adopted this strategy early on
because of the precedent of
separate but equal the separate but
equal doctrine
established in the 1896 case of plessy b
ferguson
so the naacp contested legal segregation
not by arguing that it itself was
unconstitutional
but only if they separated citizens
according to race
in an unequal way
the idea was to make segregation too
expensive
especially for southern states southern
state governments to maintain
if a state provided a public park a
library a pool a golf course
but only did so it was public but only
did so for whites
but it didn't provide one equally
for black citizens or they provided one
of inferior quality
the naacp would say ah this violates the
14th amendment which says
again nor shall any state deny to any
person within its jurisdiction
the equal protection of the laws
in case after case in the first half of
the 20th century
the naacp won court case after court
case
in the highest court of the land using
this strategy
showing that racial segregation was
never applied or not applied
equally and it forced states to provide
equal accommodations or
if they lack the funds to eliminate the
segregated facility
altogether well the problem was that
after a while
southern states that had been
segregating but could not afford to do
so on an equal basis
they just decided to close it all down
close the public facility
rather than desegregate them or provide
an equivalent one
for black citizens more importantly
in terms of the jurisprudence that the
naacp was pursuing here
with each victory they were actually
reinforcing legal segregation
by reinforcing the precedent of separate
but equal that was established way
back in 1896. so by the 1940s
the legal defense fund finally decided
to attack
segregation head-on and they invited the
supreme court to overturn
its decision in plessy now this is a
risky or was a risky strategy given how
much
the high court likes to stick to
previous decisions they don't like to
admit that they were ever wrong
especially precedents that had been on
the books for so long
in all four lower court cases dealing
with segregated schools
the courts had followed the plessy
doctrine of separate but equal
they ruled that if the conditions of the
schools
were basically equal the constitution
was not violated
even if the educational outcomes the
results of that
segregated education were unequal
why were the low courts the lower courts
so focused
on the inputs uh for example buildings
curricula
qualifications of the teachers their
salaries
rather than the effect that segregated
or separate but equal conditions we're
having on children
for this we have to go back to the
court's reasoning in plessy
so some quick facts about the plessy
case homer plessy
was 7 8 caucasian and 1 8
african blood as the testimony said
though the african-ness if you will was
not
discernible you couldn't tell by looking
at homer plessy
that he was part black he deliberately
rode in a railway railroad car in
louisiana that was only traveling within
the state of louisiana
he deliberately rode in a car for
white passengers and actually had to tip
the conductor to the fact that oh
by the way i'm 1 8 black so this was a
contrived case he did this deliberately
so that this could be thrown
into court so homer plessy a local
citizens committee actually worked with
the railroads
because they thought it was expensive to
segregate they didn't want this either
so they work to try to get this case uh
to the supreme court which they did
you have to remember at this time even
though he was 1 8
black we were operating this country was
operating under what's known as the one
drop rule
so it didn't matter how caucasian you
were
if you had one drop of a particular
other race or ethnicity
that's what they counted you as and this
you could trace this back agree florida
had a one drop rule all the way back
uh dating to 1866.
an important part of the plessy case was
the text of the 1890 louisiana statute
that required separate railway carriages
for whites and what they called the
colored race and this is what the text
says
that all railway companies carrying
passengers in their coaches
in this state shall provide equal
but separate accommodations for the
white
and colored races by providing two or
more passenger coaches
for each passenger train or by dividing
the passenger coaches by a partition so
as to secure
equal accommodations and it added and
this is very important
no person or persons
shall be admitted to occupy seats in
coaches other than the ones assigned to
them
on account of the race they belong to
justice brown interpreted the equal
protection clause of the 14th amendment
quote
to enforce the absolute equality
of the two races before the law end
quote
however he read this to mandate equality
of
treatment not equality of outcome
or social or public perception just
because
whites must sit in this railway carriage
and blacks must sit in that railway
carriage
he says this does not impose a badge of
inferiority
on either race moreover state
legislatures he said had long been
allowed to separate the races
in public venues as part of their
traditional what is known as
police powers justice brown gives the
example
actually of segregated schools even in
the states where the rights of blacks
had been quote most earnestly enforced
end quote
so this was a long-standing practice
justice brown gets to the crux of the
issue when he says the case comes down
to
whether the statute of louisiana is a
reasonable
regulation his answer
there must necessarily be a large
discretion
on the part of the legislature which he
argues is
at liberty to act with reference to
established usages customs and
traditions of the people
and with the view to the promotion of
their comfort and the preservation of
the public peace
and good order now all of this of course
was a euphemism for maintaining the
status quo
which of course was white supremacy
given this practice
the court concluded that quote we cannot
say
that a law which authorizes or even
requires the separation of the two races
in public conveyances is unreasonable or
more obnoxious to the 14th amendment
than the acts of congress requiring
separate schools
for colored children in the district of
columbia the constitutionality of which
does not seem to have been questioned
or the corresponding acts of state
legislatures end quote
so this reasonableness standard or we
now call the rational basis test
it actually is the lowest threshold for
state action to be considered
constitutional or unconstitutional
especially under the 14th amendment's
equal protection clause so the court
therefore allows
large discretion by the states if they
employ at that time
and for decades racial segregation when
regulating public interaction
between the races but what if racial
segregation
produces a perception that one race is
inferior to another
right a badge of inferiority justice
brown addresses this directly in a
passage that
chief justice earl warren will later
reject
to arrive at the opposite conclusion and
this is 60 years later in the brown case
so here's what plessy the plessy court
concluded we consider the underlying
fallacy of the plaintiff's argument to
consist in the assumption
that the enforced separation of the two
races
stamps the colored race with a badge of
inferiority
if this be so it is not by reason of
anything
found in the act or the statute but
solely because the colored race
chooses to put that construction or that
interpretation
upon it in other words any feeling of
inferiority
as a result of racial segregation is not
the product of government policy
as long as that racial policy is equally
applied
the court's separate but equal doctrine
does not
actually make any citizen inferior
therefore if someone does feel inferior
because of race
racial classification that's because
that person
chooses to interpret it that way
in the one dissenting opinion the
opinion of justice marshall
john marshall harlan he thinks that this
reading of the statute
is absurd everyone knows that this law
and other segregation laws are intended
to maintain
a legal or at least a social hierarchy
of whites over blacks he also doesn't
think
courts especially the supreme court
should inquire
into the so-called reasonableness or
wisdom
of state legislatures the only question
the supreme court should try to answer
he thought was does the state law
comport with the constitution and in
this case it's the equal protection
clause of the 14th amendment
in his mind the court the court
recognizes
no caste or superior ruling
class of citizens he then cited a
concept that was
actually first presented at oral
argument by
the lead attorney for homer plessy and
that was a guy named albion torche
oral argument he observed quote if
justice is pictured blind
then the law at least should be
colorblind
here's how justice harlan put it in his
descent
our constitution is colorblind
and neither knows nor tolerates classes
among citizens
in respect of civil rights all citizens
are equal before the law he added the
law regards man
as man and takes no account of his
surroundings or of his color
when his civil rights are guaranteed by
the
supreme law of the land so
given so many subsequent cases that
relied upon plessy
as precedent how did the warren court in
1954
rule unanimously to reject the separate
but equal doctrine
in its short i think it's nine pages uh
plainly written ruling
the new chief justice justice war earl
warren
argued that americans in the mid 20th
century now lived in a different
world than that of the 1896
plessy court most importantly education
was now a leading function
of state government it was now
compulsory
supported by a substantial budget and
had become as warren put it
the very foundation of good citizenship
so if the state became the educator of
its citizens
then it was responsible according to
warren not just for the educational
inputs but for what those inputs
produced the educational outcomes
such an opportunity earl warren said
where the state has undertaken to
provide it
is a right which must be made available
to all on equal terms
to get around the plessy doctrine of
separate but equal chief justice warren
leaned on
more recent precedents sweat b painter
and maclaurin v oklahoma 1950
to include what he called intangible
considerations in the educational
process
not just inputs material ones like
buildings or teacher qualifications
things you could measure
but also the learning environment and
this is key
what that environment produced the
results
as he put it we must look instead to the
effect
of segregation segregation itself
its effect on public education he
concluded that to separate
to separate children from others of
similar
age and qualification solely because of
their race
generates a feeling of inferiority
as to their status in the community that
may affect their hearts and minds
in a way unlikely ever to be undone
so when government segregates children
according to race
and this separation produces feelings of
inferiority
then government is now responsible for
that outcome
it's not simply an interpretation or
construction
that children choose to put on their
racially
segregated school the court ruled that
in the field of public education
the doctrine of separate but equal has
no place separate educational
facilities are inherently unequal
now few court observers disputed the
decision
the result in this case but many
question the reasoning
especially its reliance upon
psychological tests
to determine the effects of racial
segregation upon segregated students
to decide if the constitution was
violated by a government
use of race on the basis of feelings
generated seemed like a dubious basis
for determining if a person's rights
under the constitution
were infringed think about it
what if a segregated school didn't
generate a feeling of inferiority
would there be no violation of the equal
protection clause of the 14th amendment
and if not did brown actually overturn
plessy now if brown decided that
government could not
pay attention to race couldn't separate
students on the basis of race in k-12
schools
public schools the second case involving
education
ruled that government could use race in
higher education
not to separate not to separate but to
promote
diversity what they call the educational
benefits that flow from a racially
diverse student body
so we now shift our discussion of
government use of racial classifications
from segregation or desegregation
to the policy known today as affirmative
action
it should go without saying that using
race in a constitutional way
means you're not operating according to
a colorblind constitution
we'll see how the supreme court
justifies this under the 14th
amendment's
equal protection clause the key case
is actually two cases in 2003 involving
the university of michigan
their law school and their undergraduate
university
they're the cases of gruder v bollinger
and grotzvy bollinger respectively
now the supreme court upheld affirmative
action as it was practiced in the law
school
but it rejected affirmative action that
operated
differently at the undergraduate
university
the key precedent for justice sandra day
o'connor who
took all the supreme court affirmative
action cases when she was on the court
her key precedent was a case that had
been on the books for 25 years the 1978
case of regents fibaki
unlike the brown decision which only
relied on the 14th amendment back in
1954.
o'connor's opinion drew from two
provisions of the constitution and
in this she was following justice powell
in bauchi
the equal protection clause of the 14th
amendment for sure
but also because it dealt with higher
education
the free speech clause of the first
amendment
reasonableness or the rational basis
test was the prevailing court standard
until about world war ii when two cases
dealing with japanese internment
the hirobayashi case in 1943 and the
koromatsu case of 1944
these led the court to adopt a new more
rigorous
measure of constitutionality when it
came to race
racial classifications by government
were now considered by the court
immediately suspect they weren't
categorically unconstitutional
unconstitutional they've never ruled
that
but they were immediately suspect and
subject to as the court put it
the most rigid scrutiny
so they're moving off of reasonableness
and ratcheting it up
a bit this is now known as the strict
scrutiny
test and it's a test that has two prongs
both of which
have to pass in order for a government
use of race
to be considered constitutional number
one
it has to serve a compelling
state interest it has to be a priority
of the state
government and that also includes the
federal government now
secondly it has to be narrowly tailored
to meet that state interest
so you have a constitutionally
permissible end that you're looking for
and a corresponding constitutional means
to securing that end if you're using
race
so at the university of michigan
affirmative action was used again
one way at the law school and another
way at the undergraduate university
the difference between the two policies
produced the different
outcomes as o'connor and then rehnquist
in the in the kratz
case um applied strict scrutiny
so what were they doing at the law
school um they were
looking at students according to race
especially those that they considered
under represented minorities um
we'll use the acronym urm okay
so they would favor urms to produce what
they called a
critical mass or meaningful
representation of blacks
hispanics and native americans and if
you listen to the oral arguments i
remember
being on the interstate 66 on my way to
dc and actually listening i think this
is one of the first court cases where
they actually
um i think this was on npr they actually
let you
listen to what was actually being said
the michigan attorney was fantastic
whatever they paid her they should have
given her a raise
because scalia and the conservative
justices were leaning in on her they're
trying to see if they could say that she
that michigan was employing a quota and
they said hmm
critical mass could you define critical
mass for us and she said yeah
meaningful representation of urms and
they're like
what's meaningful representation so she
used an absolute number
or a fixed percentage or a narrow band
that they were looking for they would
have lost even the liberals on the court
would have
said you can't do that you know what she
did she just said
critical mass she just bounced back and
forth critical mass meaningful
representation until the justices gave
up
so critical mass second the state of
michigan
argued that it had a compelling interest
to diversify the student body
in order to enhance the education of its
law students
so how do you get educational diversity
free exchange of ideas
you can use race to help promote that
lastly it claimed that its pursuit of a
critical mass was
not a quota which had been disallowed
in the precedent of baki 25 years
earlier
now because the case dealt with higher
education
right colleges and grad schools like law
schools
justice o'connor drew from powell's
bache opinion
to argue that not one but two
constitutional provisions as i mentioned
earlier
needed to be balanced or reconciled to
determine if the law school's
use of race was justified now we've got
the equal protection clause which i'm
sure you're here
you're tired of me mentioning but
they're all over it
you have on the one hand the equal
protection clause of the 14th amendment
but then you also have the first
amendment's free speech clause
now why courts have long treated
colleges and universities as a special
niche
in constitutional adjudication the
nature of education
they believe requires academic freedom
and
so what do they say they respected the
university's need
the law school in this case to determine
how best to promote
the exchange of ideas necessary for the
education of their students
if racial diversity could help in this
regard the court was not going to second
guess this is important
they were going to defer
to michigan's educational autonomy as
they called it
as it pursued what they considered to be
a compelling state interest
even though you've got this
constitutional requirement that no state
shall deny to any person
the equal protection of the laws so in
satisfying the first
prong of the strict scrutiny test let me
make a few observations about o'connor's
reasoning
first she presumes and she calls it this
she presumes good
faith on the part of the university when
it claims that hey
hey we're only using race
to promote this educational end
now what's interesting about this if the
court is deferring to them
if you will granting them large
discretion
in its use of race doesn't that sound an
awful lot like
justice brown's reasoning in plessy
second because the bakke precedent from
1978 ruled that redressing historical
wrongs the thing that you would think
affirmative action would be all about
justice powell said no you can't claim
that your specific affirmative action
policy is going to
redress or provide a remedy for
historical harms that were done
to racial minorities so he actually said
you can't justify racial classifications
by saying
we're trying to repair the damage of
previous discrimination
the only purpose for powell and
o'connor borrowed this the only purpose
that passed constitutional muster was
racial diversity as a means of promoting
promoting educational diversity
what's curious here is michigan provides
a
counter-intuitive explanation for its
promotion of diversity
here it is they argued that they needed
to include
more underrepresented minorities to
break down
stereotypes you don't want to have a
token native american or black person or
hispanic
in class because otherwise the majority
white student body would think oh yeah
that's the way all blacks think
in short you see what they did
affirmative action is justified not
because it helps racial minorities
but because it helps the white kids
that's an interesting turn of events
what o'connor called effective
participation
she saw was promoted by a law school
that enrolled a sufficient number right
meaningful representation of urms
this showed in her mind the path of
leadership being
visibly open to talented and qualified
individuals
of every race and ethnicity and although
o'connor claimed that race was not to be
understood as a proxy
for a specific way that all members of
that race thought
a critical mass of urms lets the law
school
demonstrate right visibly that it is
training a diverse group
of attorneys and therefore leading to
the enhancement of the integrity
and trustworthiness of those who will
eventually assume roles of leadership
in the nation now
satisfied the first prong of strict
scrutiny what about that
narrowly tailored part we're moving from
ends
to means the 14th amendment protects and
o'connor
is a stickler for this it protects
individual persons
not groups therefore affirmative action
that is constitutional
must ensure what o'connor again drawing
from
the bakke opinion of powell called
individualized consideration
any policy that amounts to a racial
quota we're just going to set aside a
certain number of seats
uh like a dual track admission system or
any other sort of
mechanistic treatment of applicants
doesn't treat each applicant as an
individual
person and therefore in her mind would
violate the equal protection clause
while race can act as a plus
it cannot be what she called the
defining
feature of a person's application
o'connor's majority opinion in gruder
v bolinger was a split decision
five supporting affirmative action at
the law school and four
arguing to reject it that's a pretty
tight pretty close decision
so this made though gruter stronger than
baki because that baki precedent was
peculiar in the sense that powell had an
opinion
that no other justice joined you're like
well how could that be the precedent
well four justices agreed with part of
powell's
decision or reasoning and four other
justices
agreed with a different part and that's
how powell's
opinion became the precedent even though
it wasn't technically a majority
opinion then chief justice william
rehnquist
he dissented in the gruder case arguing
that the close parallels
between the percentage of urms who
applied
and the percentage who were accepted
in any given year year over year
proved that the law school was in fact
employing a quota to reach its critical
mass
of racial minorities in other words it
was looking to see well how many
out of the whole pool applied okay we
need to make sure
roughly that many get accepted
and so he says man this is an obvious
failure of the narrowly tailored test
they're not being treated as individuals
as for the undergraduate university use
of race and admissions
the grotts v bollinger case the supreme
court ruled that by awarding
20 points automatically to every urm
applicant
the university did not treat them as
individual persons
and therefore they were using race in a
way that ensured
their acceptance rehnquist wrote the
majority opinion
in gratz but he had uh had to follow the
gruder precedent
in order to reach his conclusion and it
was a conclusion
that o'connor joined and so that was a
six to three decision so to wrap things
up here frederick douglass devoted his
adult life
to getting white americans as he put it
to trust the operation of its
own principles or as king put it all we
ask
is that you be true to what you said on
paper
that paper was the declaration of
independence and the constitution
which king viewed as a promissory note
to which
every american was to fall air
a colorblind constitution would seem to
be a logical implementation of the
colorblind ideals
of the declaration of independence but
the supreme court essentially has left
us with two conclusions about government
use of racial classifications under the
constitution
number one government can't pay
attention to race
when it involves assigning students to
public schools at the k-12
grade levels number two
government can pay attention to race
if it involves colleges and graduate
schools like law schools
and their exercise of academic freedom
in pursuit
of the educational diversity that flows
from racial diversity
in the end as long as the supreme court
continues to apply
a strict scrutiny test to determine if
affirmative action
or any other race-based program whether
in college admissions
hiring and promotion or awarding
government contracts
a color-blind constitution is nowhere
in sight
you